İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar 18 Aralık 2024 çarşamba günü saat 19.31 9. ders günümüz dersimize başlıyoruz kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar arkadaşlar geçen dersin sonunda SDR'deki bazı algoritmalara bakıyorduk
ve en son kaldığımız yer yanlış hatırlamıyorsam search algoritmasıydı arkadaşlar C'de herkes str str fonksiyonunu hatırlıyor mu bir soru günlük sorusu C'nin string.h modülünde string kütüphanesinde str str fonksiyonunu hatırlıyor musunuz
str str fonksiyonu bir yazı içinde bir yazı arıyor değil mi şöyle bir fonksiyon değil mi const char yıldız
char yıldız
str str
const char yıldız p1
const char yıldız p2
p1 adresindeki yazı da p2 adresindeki yazıyı arıyor
örneğin mecati bugün ders anlatıyor yazısında bugün yazısını arasaydım bulurdum
şimdi bunun genelleştirilmiş halini düşünün
yani herhangi bir rençte herhangi bir renci aradığımızı düşünün
yani örneğin 8-3-5-7-9-1-6-4-2
böyle bir rencimiz olsun tam sayılardan oluşan
tıpkı str str'de olduğu gibi burada 5-7-9'u arayalım
5-7-9 renci burada var değil mi?
işte search'ün yaptığı bu arkadaşlar
search'ün yaptığı bu
ve bunlardan ilkini buluyor
burada da tarihsel süreç içinde bazı isimlendirme yanlışları yapılmış
mesela bu fonksiyonun ismi search
fakat bir de findend isimli bir fonksiyon var
findend fonksiyonu aslında search'ün yaptığının aynısını yapıyor
fakat en sondakini buluyor
evet
yani ilkini değil de sonuncuyu buluyor
örneğin şöyle olsaydı
ve ben 5-7-9'u arasaydım
yukarıdaki rençte
search fonksiyonu bana burayı bulacaktı
dolayısıyla döndürdüğü adres şu adres olacaktı
ve search
mesela search and deal fonksiyonun ismi findend
findend fonksiyonu da nereyi bulacaktı
şu konumu bulacaktı
ama tabi herhangi bir renç olabilir
arkadaşlar bu search ya da findend fonksiyonları sorted range algoritms değil ama onlara giriş için bu örneği vermiştim
bir de sorted range algoritms grubunda include fonksiyonu var
include fonksiyonu ise şunu yapıyor
search'da biraz bahsetmiştim belki fonksiyonun ismini söylemedim
2-7-9-12 bu bir sıralı range olsun 23-45-87
bu sıralı range de şu sekans arka arkaya olması gerekmiyor
bunu içeriyor mu?
7-12-23'ü içeriyor mu?
evet
yani şöyle de düşünebilirsiniz
belirli öğeler silinirse 7-12-23'e erişilebilir mi?
evet
include
search
farklı bir search
ama normal search'de search
findend
bir de searchend isimli bir fonksiyon var
searchend isimli fonksiyon da ne yapıyor?
belirli bir değerden n tanenin bulunduğu sekansı buluyor
yani örneğin
searchende de örnek verelim sonra hepsi için kod yazalım
örneğin
3-7
burada da sortlet olması gerekmiyor
2-2-2
8-8-8-8
mesela ben burada 3 tane 2'yi arasaydım
burayı bulacaktı
2 tane 8'i arasaydım burayı bulacaktı
3 tane 8'i arasaydım burayı bulacaktı
4 tane 8'i arasaydım burayı bulacaktı
bu fonksiyonların ne yaptığını anladık değil mi?
o zaman bir search var
bir searchend var
arkadaşlar
bir findend var
hepsini bir yazalım
findend
bir searchend var
bir de
sorted range
algoritmes grubunda
arkadaşlar
include var
include
evet
şimdi bunları
tek tek bir görelim
algoritm başlık dosyasını
iostream
başlık dosyasını
bizim test için oluşturduğumuz
neutrality başlık dosyalarını ekleyelim
ve önce
search'te
yine başlayalım
arkadaşlar
bu sefer
string sınıfı üstünde
çalışalım
ilk örneğimizde
bir
vektör konteynerı
kullanalım
ve vektörün
string açılımı
esvek
efendim
kaya
mert
hepsi dört harika olsun
takip etmek kolay olsun
esra
nuri
edis
efendim sefa
ya da salfa
ayça
yeter
hadi bir tane daha olsun
sula
ayla
yeter
arkadaşlar bakın şimdi
const
auto
list
eşittir
initializer list
oluşturayım
esra
nuri
edis
search
sıralı olarak arayan sadece inkulu
bunların hiçbiri sıralı değil arayan
evet
ben örneği sıralıdan vermiştim
önce inkulu da anlatacaktım
sonra
belki
orada bir dil sürçmesi olmuş olabilir hatırlamıyorum
evet
search
bakın şu şimdi
birinci ve ikinci parametre
kaynak range
yani içinde arama yapılacak range
üçüncü ve dördüncü parametre
arkadaşlar
nedir
aranacak
öğeleri içeren range
yani o zaman şöyle olacak
esvekbegin
esvekend
listbegin
bu arada iteratör grubuna da bakın arkadaşlar
bunlar
random axis iteratör istemiyor
gördüğünüz gibi
iteratör kategorisi
şuradan başlayalım
takip ediyor musunuz
evet
search
esvekbegin
esvekend
listbegin
listend
arkadaşlar bir şeye daha bakmanızı istiyorum
şimdi
bu tür algoritmalar
şu kamera görüntüsü
evet
bu tür algoritmaların hepsinde geri dönüş değeri
ya range'in endi bulamazsa
bulursa da range'in başladığı arananın bulunduğu yer ya da başladığı yer
birden fazla ve söz konusuysa
şimdi geri dönüş değerini
bir
iteratörde tutalım
ve arkadaşlar
iteratörümüzün
değeri
esvek'in
endi
tabi tabi forward iteratör her zaman asgari olarak istedi
evet
şimdi bakın
şurada tekrar göstereyim
buradaki
isimlendirme de
visual studio'da biraz kötü olduğu için kafa karıştırıyor
ben cpp referansı da açayım
hep algoritmaları dokümante ederken
minimal kategori belirtilir
stut
search
cpp refer
evet bakın şu algoritma
evet
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz bakın forward iteratör ama iki ayrı iteratör range'i var
yani kaynak range ile içinde arama yapılacak range ile aramada kullanılacak range
aynı kategoride olmak zorunda değil
mesela vektörte listedeki öğelerin range'ini arayabilirim
evet
şimdi
iter eşit değildir
svek end
arkadaşlar
o zaman if'in doğru kısmına girerse bulundu
see out
count
hatta şöyle yapalım
index'e dönüştürelim
idx
count
idx eşittir
iter
eksi
esvek
begin
see out
başladığı yeri de yazalım
yıldız iter
evet
arkadaşlar
hatta şöyle bir kod bile yazabiliriz
değil mi
biz şimdi
iter'i bulduk
diğer range'deki öğe sayısını da biliyoruz
o da list'in size'ı
değil mi
ya da aradaki fark
mesela orayı dolaşıp
o öğeler üstünde
bir set işlemi de yapabilirdik
ama
şimdilik basit bu kodla yetinelim
as
see out
count
şimdi
bakın
count
index eşittiri 2
esra
gördüğünüz gibi burayı buldu
eğer şöyle olsaydı
arkadaşlar
esra
nuri ediz değil de
şurayı değiştirelim
ya da şurayı değiştirelim
bakın
buraya bir tane daha koyuyorum
esra
nuri
ediz
şimdi
search'ü değil
find and'i
kullanayım
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakın aradaki farka
yani
search'le find and
aslında
birbirinin tersi
biri
ilk bulunduğu yeri
tespit ediyor
buluyor
yiğit
diğeri
son bulunduğu yeri
buluyor
işte burada
esra nuri ediz
sekansını
search'le aradığımda
burayı buldu
ama find and'le aradığımda
şurayı buldu
değil mi
esra nuri ediz
biz
şimdi
anladık değil mi
arkadaşlar
search'le
find and
aynı işi yapan
str str'nin
c bilenler için
genelleştirilmiş
hali
diyebiliriz
ee
sıralı derken
sort'ı da
ardışık tabi
evet
arkadaşlar
ardışık
yani
contiguous olmak zorunda
sorted
olmak zorunda
değil ama
contiguous olmak zorunda
yani örneğin şöyle olur muydu
esra burada
ediz burada
o zaman
bulamamış olacaktı
anlaşıldı mı
devam
şimdi
arkadaşlar
bir de
search n'e bakalım
search n
arkadaşlar
içinde search geçiyor
burada
n şu anlamda
n tane
o değerden
arayacak
hadi bakalım
şimdi de
int
vektör
kullanalım
ivek
evet
şimdi bakın
search n
arkadaşlar
yalnız burada
bu tür algoritmaların
genelde
iki oburluğu da oluyor
n tane belirli bir değerden arayacak ya
izleyin
search n
eşitliği bir şekilde kontrol etmesi gerekiyor değil mi
eşitliği equal to ile kontrol ediyor
ama bakarsanız
algoritmanın bir overloadu daha var
o ise bizden binary predikat istiyor
yani eşitlik kriterini siz kendinizde belirleyebiliyorsunuz
önce biz binary predikat vermeyelim
örneğin
int
and
while
see out
ya da ters olsun
alırken ters sırada alacağım
hangi değerden
kaç tane
see in
while
and
search n
if
auto iter
eşittir
search n
ibek begin
ibek and
ebek
and
arkadaşlar
bakın
üçüncü parametre adet tane
yani
and
while
iter
eşit değilse
ibek in and
see out
bulundu
index
iter
eksi
ibek
begin
,
orn
kucu
begin
ars hale bulunamadı
else
see out
bulunamadı.
Eterlere bakın şimdi.
Mesela
2'den
3 tane
bulundu. İndeks eşittir 2.
Ne yaptığını anladınız değil mi?
Efendim
7'den
4 tane
burayı buldu gördüğünüz gibi.
2'den
2 tane
arkadaşlar
birbül girdim yanlışlıkla
2'den 2 tane
bulundu. İndeks eşittir 2.
Sörçenin ne yaptığı
ne olarak anlaşılıyor. Ama bakın
Binary Predicate burada önemli.
Şimdi burada
bir eşitlik karşılaştırması var değil mi?
Mesela şöyle olsaydı
izleyin
eksi 2
şurayı değiştirelim
eksi 5
hangi değerden kaç tane
5'den 3 tane
bulunamadı.
Ama şimdi
ben bir
predikat oluşturayım.
const
auto
f
equal
eşittir
lambda
int a
int b
arkadaşlar
return
a
stu
a b s
a
eşit eşit
stu
a b s
b
artık
üveylerin
eşitliğini
kontrol etmek için
bu fonksiyonu
kullanacak.
Bu fonksiyon da
mutlak değerlerin
eşitliği.
mesela
hangi değerden
geçmemişim argümanı
son parametreye
f
eq
hangi değerden kaç tane
5'den 4 tane
bakın bulundu.
Neden bulundu?
çünkü bunlar artık
eşit kabul edilecek.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Böylece
arkadaşlar
neyi de
göstermiş olduk?
Search'ini de
göstermiş olduk.
Şimdi
sorted range
algorithms
grubuna
geçersek
orada
eksik ol
oradaki fonksiyonları
şöyle bir hatırlatalım.
Hatta göstereyim
yine ben
cpp
reference
dot com'dan
müsaadenizle.
Bakın
algoritim
eksik kalmasın.
En azından
temel algoritmaların
hepsini görmüş olalım.
Bakın şimdi bunlar
copy fonksiyonları.
Bunlar
swap fonksiyonları.
Transformation
ve
generation
bu generation
grubundan
filini
generate'i
gördük.
Removing
operations
remove'u
remove if'i
unique'i
arkadaşlar
remove copy'i
remove copy if'i
gördük.
Order changing
operations
demiş
reverse'i gördük.
Rotate'i
görmedik.
Arkadaşlar
c++20 ile
eklenen
shift left
shift right
bunları görmedik.
Random
shuffle
ve shuffle
bunları görmedik
ama bunları da
göreceğiz.
Yine c++17 ile
eklenen
sample algoritması
var.
Onu da
görmedik.
Ama
neyse
hepsini
geçelim.
Şimdi
işte
set operations
dediği
sorted range
algoritması
arkadaşlar.
Yani şu
grup ve şu
grup
mouse'u da
açalım.
Evet
göstergemizi
de açalım.
Nerede?
Şuradasın.
Evet.
İşte bakın
şu grup
includes
set union
set intersection
bunları gördük.
set difference
gördük değil mi
bu fonksiyonları?
Set symmetric
difference
buranın yanlış
hatırlamıyorum
de bunları
gördük.
Ve
merge
in place
yani buradaki
merge
sıralı
birleştirme
arkadaşlar.
Ama şimdi
ben sadece
includes'u
göstermek istiyorum.
Bakın ne
diyor?
Returns
true
if one
sequence
is a
subsequence
of
another
yani
bir sekans
başka bir
sekansın
alt sekansıysa
onu kapsıyorsa
o zaman
true değer
döndürecek.
Şimdi
hemen
includes için de
örnek yapalım.
Bu sefer
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
20 tane
ve olsun
generate
ivek begin
ivek end
generator
olarak
ivek
sort
ediyorum
ivek
begin
end
hatta
yazdıralım
jprint
ivek
buraya kadar
değerliyelim.
Evet gördüğünüz gibi
sıralı bir
range.
Şimdi
geçen yazdığım
test kodunu
yazıyorum.
Arkadaşlar
int
x
y
z
tabii
üç tane
olmak zorunda
değil.
cout
küçükten
büyüğe
üç
sayı
giriniz
ve
c'in
x
y
z
Arkadaşlar
includes
bakınız
doğrudan
zaten
boolean
değer döndürüyor.
birinci
ikinci parametre
içinde arama
yapılacak
range
üçüncü
dördüncü
parametrede
aranacak
öğelerin
bulunduğu
range.
O zaman
doğrudan
if
ile
aramayı
yapalım.
if
includes
şurada
deneyim liste
oluşturalım.
initializer liste
auto list
includes
ıvek
begin
end
list
begin
serdi.
Evet
baş
hayır
yok
evet
burada
ıvek
begin
end
ilist
begin
end
bir yerde
bir
hata
var
daha
ilerleyelim
evet
bir yerde
sentax
hatası
var
evet
bir blok
tutmuyor
şöyle
bakalım
şunu
silelim
bunu da
list
begin
end
bir parantez
daha eksik
şimdi oldu
evet
ip
kapanmamış
ben de
sorudan
göre
küçükten
büyüğe
3 sayı
bakın
şöyle
ama
deneyeyim
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
demin
arkadaşımın
Alihan'ın
sorduğu
bu
artışık
olması
gerekiyor
mu
burada
gerekmiyor
ve
evet
var
anlaşıldı
değil mi
bu da
includes
algoritması
binary
search
algoritması
var
diğer
arama
algoritması
da
arkadaşlar
binary
search
algoritması
da
sıralanmış
bir rençte
bir değeri
arıyor
yalnız
burada
bir şeye
dikkat
bu
algoritmaların
hepsinin
sıralama
kriteri
var
çünkü
sıralıysa
sıralı
tanımı
olması
gerekiyor
eğer
ben
bir
binary
predikat
vermiyorsam
o
overload
her zaman
l'si
kullanıyordur
yani
örneğin
bunu
büyükten
küçüğe
sıralasaydım
arkadaşlar
evek
begin
end
reverse
teratörle
de yapabilirdim
greater
functor
kullanayım
greater
function
object
standart
functional
başlık
dosyası
da
şimdi
ama bu
seferde
şöyle
diyecektim
büyükten
küçüğe
3 sayı
giriniz
ve
5.
parametreye
de
yine
komparatörümü
verecektim
evet
mesela
var
ve
evet
arkadaşlar
o zaman
biz şimdi artık
kaldığımız yerden
devam edebiliriz
ara ara
eksik kalan
algoritmaları
da göstereceğim
amacım
bu
range kütüphanesi
haricindeki
bütün
algoritmaları
tamamlamak
yani
belki bir iki tane
eksik kalabilir ama
hepsini
tamamlayacağımızı
umuyorum
şimdi yeni bir
başlığımız var
yeni alt başlığımız
bit set
arkadaşlar
bit set bir
konteyner değil
önce bu konuda
anlaşalım
yani konteyner
olsaydı
zaten
konteyner
grubunda
belirtirdik
bit set
aslında
en tane
boolean
değeri
benlikle
ardışık
olarak
tutan
yani bunları
bit değeri
olarak
kullanabileceğimiz
hastaya
adı üstünde
bitlerden
oluşan
bir set
non-type
template
parametreye
sahip
yani
aslında
şöyle bir
sınıftan
bahsediyoruz
arkadaşlar
template
tut
size
de
en
plus
mid set
üretimde
kesinlikle
kullanmaya
aday olduğunuz
birçok yerde
işinize yarayacak
bir sınıf
arkadaşlar
böyle bir sınıfın
böyle bir sınıf
türünden
bir nesneyi
örneğin
true
false
değerlerden
oluşan
bir
ne olarak
kullanabilirsiniz
veri yapısı
olarak
kullanabilirsiniz
örneğin
en tane
bitin
her biri
efendim
bir kapının
açık mı
kapalı mı
olduğu
bir lidin
yanar
durumda mı
sönmüş
olduğunu
ya o değerde
ya bu değerde
olduğunu test ediyor
olabilir
ama normal
bitsel işlemler
içinde
kullanabilirsiniz
sınıfımızın
operatör
fonksiyonları
bitsel işlemler
için
overload edilmiş
yani
bitsel sola
kaydırma
bitsel sağa
bitsel ve
bitsel veya
bitsel özel
veya
yani
exor
hepsi
operatör overloading
mekanizmasıyla
sunulmuş
ayrıca
dönüşüm
fonksiyonlarımız
var
tam sayıdan
bit sete
ya da
bit setten
tam sayıya
string sınıfından
bit sete
ya da bit set sınıfından
string sınıfına
bir şekilde
aktarım
yapabiliyorum
ve aynı şekilde
insörter
ve ekstraktör
fonksiyonları da var
yani
streamlere
insert edebiliyorum
o streame
ve
iStream
sınıflarında
ekstrakt edebiliyorum
arkadaşlar
hemen
yavaş yavaş
görelim
mesela
önce başlık dosyasından
başlayalım
başlık dosyası
bit set
bunun bir
sınıf şablonu
olduğunu
template parametresinin
non-type template
parametri olduğunu
unutmayalım
yani
şöyle olacak
bit setin
örneğin
8 açılımı
bu bir sınıf
bit setin
12 açılımı
bir sınıf
yani
8'in katları
byte'in katları
falan olması
gerekmiyor
bit setin
32 açılımı
bir sınıf
bizi ilgilendiren
belleklerin
şekilde tutulduğu
derleyici ilgilendiriyor
ama derleyiciler
tipik olarak
arkadaşlar
kelimenin katları
kadar yer ayırıyorlar
yani onu da bir
göstereyim
mesela
size of
bit set
ya da
eşittir
size of
bit set
yani
çok çok fazla
bit kullanmadığınız sürece
kopyalanma maliyeti
ciddi boyutta değil
görüyorsunuz
sadece 4 byte
16 olsaydı da 4 byte
olacaktı
32 olsaydı da 4 byte
mesela 34 yapalım
tipik olarak şimdi
iki kelime tutacak
arkadaşlar
34 yapalım
bit set 8 yazmışım
34 yazalım
heminki örnekte hepsi
bit set 8 olarak
denilmiş
bakın 34
bu derleyiciye
bağlı tabi
gördüğünüz gibi
arkadaşlar
bit set nesnesini
default olarak
construct edebiliyorum
önce
constructor grubundan
başlayalım
ondan sonra
yavaş yavaş
diğer grupları
göreceğiz
default
construct edilmiş
bir bit setin
bütün
bitleri
arkadaşlar
sıfır
yani örneğin
bit set
x
cout
inserter olduğunu
söylemiştim
ama
sınıfın
birden fazla
konstruktörü var
bu
default
konstruktör
konstruktör edilmiş
bir bit set
destesinin
bütün bitleri
sıfır
arkadaşlar
bu arada
emek
bunu da söyleyelim
bakın
farklı
template
specializationları
farklı türler
yani
bit set
16x
8y
x eşittir
y
sent
x
çünkü bunların
türleri
ayrı
bunu defalarca
konuştuk
farklı
specializationlar
farklı türler
bunların arasında
arasında bir dönüşüm
yapacak fonksiyon
olmadığı sürece
bunlar arasında
bir dönüşüm
ilişkisi
yok
konstruktörlerimizden
bir tanesi
arkadaşlar
string alıyor
bir tanesi
c string alıyor
yani örneğin
şöyle
başlatabilirim
see out
x
görüyorsunuz değil mi
sınıfın size fonksiyonu
template argümanına
döndürüyor
see out
x'in size'ı
burada tabi ki
iteratör veren
tabi ki
arka planda
derleyicinin
ürettiği kod
arkadaşlar
bit set
operatörleri
kullanıyor
muhtemelen
ama o tabi ki
derleyiciye bağlı
bizi ilgilendiren
bizim nasıl
hizmet alacağımız
size fonksiyonu
gördüğünüz gibi
16 değerini
döndürdü
arkadaşlar
bakalım
exception
throw etmesi
için
bu sefer
buraya
bir
örneğin
3 değeri
koyalım
bakın
exception
gönderdi
yakalandı
invalid
bit set
char
vat yazısının
döndürdüğü
adres
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
diğer
constructorlara
gelelim
string
constructorı
var
string
parçak dosyasını
ekleyelim
ki
bit set
kendisi
eklemiş olacak
string
str
arkadaşlar
0 1
ama şimdi
buraya dikkat edin
string
constructorı
ilginç
özelliklere
sahip
bir kere
doğrudan
şöyle
başlatabilirim
bit set
32 açılımı
bs
std
siyahat
bs
belirli
indeksten
başlayarak
belirli
adet
karakterden
oluşan grubu
alabilirim
bit set
bs
str
yani
şöyle yorum
satırı ile
gösterelim
arkadaşlar
indekseme
0 ile
başlıyor
tane
gördünüz
değil mi
tabi
yukarıdaki bitler
yine
0 olacak
efendim
böyle çalıştığını
göstermek için
şuraları
komple 1
yapalım
gördünüz
değil mi
arkadaşlar
6 tane
bitti
ilginç bir özelliği
daha var
konstruktörlerin
şimdi bakın
diyelim ki
siz
genetikle
ilgili
bir çalışma
yapıyorsunuz
ab ab ab ab ab
ab
ama
konstruktöre
bakın
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir
konstruktör de var
a
b
yani
a'yı
0 olarak
alacak
b'yi
true
olarak alacak
gördünüz
değil mi
evet
herkes anladı mı
özellikle bu
baya bir işe yarıyor
string'e dönüştürürken de
işe yarıyor
mesela şöyle olsaydı
xy
y
x x x
x
y
başka neler var
unsigned long
ve unsigned long long
parametreyle
arkadaşlar
daha doğrusu
unsigned long long
parametreyle
konstruktörü var
yani
örneğin
bit setin
32 açılımı
b's
derliyorum
herhangi bir
semtaks hatası yok
siyat
b's
yani bu unsigned long
değerin
bitleri neyse
benim bit setimi de
o değerle başlattı
o zaman şöyle bir sayacak olursak
cstring ya da
string ile
başlatabiliyorum
bir string'in
belirli bir
indeksinden sonraki
bütün karakterlerle
başlatabiliyorum
ve bir string'in
substring'iyle
başlatabiliyorum
üstelik
substring'i
kullandığım zaman
arkadaşlar
illa
0 1
olması gerekmiyor
o 0
false ve true
için
kullanılacak
karakterlerin
ne olması
gerektiğini de
belirtebiliyorum
şimdi artık
üye fonksiyonlara
geçeceğiz
bitleri
set etmek için
ya da reset
etmek için
ya da flip
üye fonksiyonlar
var
bitleri test
etmek için de
üye fonksiyon
var
set edilmiş
bitin
sayısının
ne olduğunu
bulmak için de
üye fonksiyon var
işte bu yüzden
bitsel işlemlerde
işimizi
çok çok
kolaylaştırıyor
arkadaşlar
bu arada
şunu da
kullanabilirsiniz
değil mi
mesela
sizin
bit set'in
32 açılımı
şöyle bir
nesnes var
mantıksal ilişki
içinde
32 tane
boolean
değer
doğrudan
bit set
nesnesinin
bitlerinde
tutulabilir
yani
bir
boolean
vektör olarak
da
kullanılabilir
burada
vektörün
boole açılımı ile
karıştırmayalım
vektörün
boole açılımı da
adeta
bir bit set
gibi kullanılabiliyor
ama o
dinamik
bellek yönetiminden
faydalanıyor
burada ise
bitler
doğrudan
nesnenin
kendi
bellek alanında
tutuluyor
evet
bakın şimdi
önce fonksiyonlara
bir bakalım
hızlı bir şekilde
any
all
none
bunlar test fonksiyonları
ya da test
hepsi şu anlamda
any
any bit set
all
all of the bit set
none
none of the bit set
test de
arkadaşlar
belirli bir bitin
bir mi sıfır mı
olduğunu
anlamak için
köşeli parantez
operatör fonksiyonu
bir proxy
sınıfı
kullanarak
arkadaşlar
size
bir proxy
nesnesi
döndürüyor
ama o proxy
nesnesinin
bu türüne
örtülü
dönüşüm yapacak
fonksiyonu var
yani
aslında
bit seviyesinde
bir nesne
yok
ama siz
oraya geldiğimi
anlayacağım
örneğin
bs köşeli parantez
dediğinizde
aslında bir
nested type
olan
reference type
türünden
bir nesne
döndürüyor
bu fonksiyon
ama onun da
bakın
flip fonksiyonu var
operatör
rule fonksiyonu var
otoma fonksiyonu var
ama bs köşeli
parantez 5'in
kendisi
boolean
değer değil
ama
booleana
dönüşebiliyor
önce
set fonksiyonundan
başlayalım
set fonksiyonunu
iki farklı
şekilde
kullanabiliyorsunuz
birincisi
argüman
göndermeden
bu durumda
bütün bitleri
set ediyor
mesela
seeout
bs
set
seeout
ps
yani
argüman
almayan
set fonksiyonu
set
all
the bits
anlamında
ama
bir indeks
verirseniz
bu
indeksteki
boolean
değeri
set ediyor
gördüğünüz gibi
tabi
indekslemenin
sıfırdan
başladığını
söylemeye
gerek yok
arkadaşlar
örneğin
size
t
idx
seeout
kaçıncı
bit
set edilsin
bakın
mesela
bir örnek
bir yazıdaki
bir karakter
olup olmadığını
belirli bir karakterin
test etmek istesem
26 tane
harf karakteri var
o zaman
bit setin
açılımında
her bir biti
sırasıyla
a'nın
var olup olmadığını
b'nin
c'nin
var olup olmadığı
bilgisini
tutmak için
kullanabilirim
scene
index
is
set
idx
o biti
set ediyor
kaçıncı bit
set edilsin
5.
bit
kaçıncı bit
set edilsin
0.
bit
kaçıncı bit
set edilsin
31.
bit
gördünüz
değil mi
aynı şekilde
arkadaşlar
reset fonksiyonu
da
sıfırlamak için
mesela
izleyin
bu sefer
eksi 1
her ne kadar
unsigned long
türünden
değilse de
bütün bitleri
1 ya
şöyle yazalım
unsigned
long long
uval
eşittir
eksi 1
uval
cout
bs
reset
tıpkı sette olduğu gibi
argüman almayan
reset fonksiyonu
bütün bitleri
sıfırlıyor
ama
argüman
olursa
mesela
5.
biti
sıfırlasın
arkadaşlar
17.
biti
sıfırlasın
hatta
bakın
döngü de yapabilirim
bitleri
sıfırladım
reset fonksiyonunun
ne yaptığını
anladınız mı
evet
flip fonksiyonu
biti ters çeviriyor
flip
zaten bu işleme
verilen isim
flip ya da
toggle'da
değil mi
mesela
başka bir değer
verdik
yazdırdım
bs
flip
yine
argüman
almazsa
arkadaşlar
bütün bitleri
flip ediyor
argüman
olursa
sadece
o biti
flip
ediyor
evet
gördüğünüz gibi
bitler
ters çevrildi
ama en son
işlemde
sıfırıncı
biti
flip ettim
birken
sıfır oldu
velibayer
set
reset
fonksiyonları
için
geçersiz
bir indeks
verirsek
tanımsız
davranış
olur
evet
onu bir gösterelim
tanımsız davranışta
exception'i
prove ediyor
yanlış bir şey
söylemişti
olmayayım
izleyin
exception yakalamaya çalışalım
yes
set
bazen ben de söylüyorum ama emin olamıyorum
yanlış da hatırlıyor olabilirim
evet
exception
doğru ediyor
şüphelendim
aklıymışım
email it
bit set
position
yani tanımsız davranış
değil
evet
bu fonksiyonların
bir başka özelliği
veriyi ki sordunuz
bu fonksiyonların
başka özelliği
fluent API'ye
uygun yazılmış
yani fonksiyonlar
geri dönüş
değeriyle
bit set
nesnesinin
kendisine
döndürüyorlar
yani örneğin
şöyle işlemler
yapabilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
bu kalsın
hayır
sitat
uygulanamaz
çünkü
template
argüman
sitat şu demek
Alihan
bir şekilde
constructora
argüman
göndereceksiniz
constructora
gönderilen
argümandan
hareketle
template
argümanları
belli olacak
ama burada
öyle bir şey
mümkün değil
değil mi
örneğin bir sayı
gönderip
template
argümanının
belli olması
için
template
argümanının
parametresinin
bir şekilde
bu değeri
alıyor
alması lazım
böyle bir
constructor yok
anladınız mı
böyle bir
constructor olsaydı
olabilirdi
ama böyle bir
constructor yok
evet
şimdi bakın
şunu da bir
göstermiş olayım
bs
set
reset
flip
yani bunun
mümkün olmasının
nedeni
bu set fonksiyonlarının
yani set
reset
flip fonksiyonlarının
geri dönüş değerlerinin
yine
bit set referans
olması
yani hangi
nesne üstünde
işlem yapıyorsanız
o nesnenin
kendisini
döndürüyor
şimdi burada
köşeli paranteze
operatör fonksiyonuna
dikkat
arkadaşlar
soru
şöyle bir
kod yazsam
burada
while
boolean
bir değer mi
cevap
hayır
bu
proxy
sınıf
deniyor
böyle sınıflara
yani yardımcı
sınıf
bir değer eşime
imkanı
olmadığı
için
o
bir
erişimde
aracılık
yapacak
arkadaşlar
bir sınıf
bu sınıfın
ismi
nest type
reference
yani
bakınız
ipid
while
name
while'in
türüne
benim
değerleyicim
tarafımdan
yakıştırılan
isim
ipinfo
sınıfını
hatırlayın
bakın
bitset
32'nin
referans
türü
ama
bu türün
fonksiyonlarına
bakalım
şimdi
tek tek
mesela
bs
köşeli parantez
ya da
vaj
nokta
true mu
false mu
kontrolünü
yapmak için
operatör
bool
fonksiyonu
var
atama
operatör
fonksiyonu
var
boolean
parametreyle
arkadaşlar
lojik değil
operatör
fonksiyonu
var
ve flip
fonksiyonu
var
bu da şu
demlek
bakın
şimdi
köşeli parantez
operatör
fonksiyonuyla
şöyle
işlemler
yapabilirim
bs
köşeli
parantez
eşittir
bs
köşeli
parantez
aslında
burada
bitler
birbirine
atanmış
gibi
görünse de
arka
planda
ne
oluyor
arka
planda
olan
şu
derleyicinin
ürettiği
bs
'nin
operatör
köşeli
parantez
fonksiyonu
çağrı
yapıyorsunuz
bunu
argüman olarak
değerine
gönderiyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
buradan
elde
ettiğiniz
o
reference
isimli
türün
operatör
atama
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
ona da
bs'nin
yine
operatör
köşeli
parantez
değerine
atıyorsunuz
yani
arkadaşlar
burada
operatör
boğul
demiş
operatör
akamı
yanlış tamamlamış
yapılan işlem
bu
anlaşıldı mı
dolayısıyla
siz
köşeli
parantez
operatörüyle
arkadaşlar
bir ifade
kullandığınızda
buradaki
operatör
boğul
fonksiyonu
eksplisit
olmadığı
için
boğula
dönüşüyor
ister
örneğin
bu bitin
set edilip
edilmediğini
test etmek
için
operatör
boğul
fonksiyonunu
çağırın
yani böyle
yazmak
buradaki
reference
isimli
sınıfın
operatör
boğul
fonksiyonuna
çağır
yapmak
demek
anlaşıldı mı
arkadaşlar
isterseniz
şöyle
atama yapın
boğul
b
eşittir
arkadaşlar
bs köşeli
parantez
burada aslında
operatör
boğul
fonksiyonu
çağırıyor
eğer bu
fonksiyon
hatırlayın
tür dönüştürme
operatör
fonksiyonlarını
eksplisit
olsaydı
örtülü
dönüşüme
izin
vermeyecekti
ama zaten
burada
örtülü
dönüşüm
varlık
nedeni
olduğu için
izin
verilmiş
ya da
bakın
mesela
ben
bunu
lojik
özür dilerim
bitsel değil
operatörün
operandı
yapsam
aslında
bu işlem
neye karşılık
geliyor
bu işlem
aslında
şuna karşılık
geliyor
iki tane
ayrı
operatör
overloading
var
bs'nin
operatör
köşeli
parantez
fonksiyonunu
çağır
onu
argüman olarak
değerini
ver
buranı
bu
fonksiyonun
geri döndürdüğü
arkadaşlar
lvalue
expression
olan
reference
türünden
nesnenin de
arkadaşlar
operatör
tilda
fonksiyonunu
çağır
yani
yukarıdaki
ifade
buna
eşdeğer
ama
şimdi
auto type
deduction
dışında
bu bizi
fazlaca
ilgilendirmiyor
bizi
ilgilendiren
adeta
bir biti
boolean
değer olarak
köşeli
parantez
operatör
fonksiyonuna
çağır
yaparak
elde
edebilirim
demin
arkadaşım
exception
throw
ediyor
mu
demişti
ya
bakın
auto
b
eşittir
bs
şimdi
derliği
çalıştırıyorum
arkadaşlar
gördüğünüz gibi
exception
throw
etmiyor
köşeli
parantez
operatör
fonksiyonları
hiçbir zaman
exception
throw
etmiyor
izleyin
köşeli
parantez
operatör
fonksiyonunun
nasıl çalıştığını
anladık mı
tabi
bundan
faydalanarak
şöyle bir
kod
yazabilirim
değil mi
örneğin
for
size
t
i
küçük
bs'nin
size
yani
artı
i
arkadaşlar
c
out
örneğin
bs
köşeli
parantez
i
şimdi
aslında
ben
boolean
değer elde
ettim
ama
boolean
yazdırırken
arkadaşlar
şu anda
boolean
modunda
olmadığı
için
true
false
olarak
yazmayacak
yazacak
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
burada
aliham
bozkır
diyor ki
sınıfın
add
fonksiyonu
var mı
hayır
burada
add
fonksiyonu
yok
köşeli
parantezle
erişebilirsiniz
ya da
set reset
flip gibi
fonksiyonlarla
belirli bir biti
manipüle
edebilirsiniz
sınıfın
test isimli
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
sınıfın
test isimli
fonksiyonu
belirli bir
bitin
set edilip edilmediğini
test ediyor
yani
örneğin
bir bitin
set olup
olmadığını
if
bs
köşeli
parantez
see out
set
as
see out
aset
bu şekilde
tespit edebileceğiniz
gibi
doğrudan
test
fonksiyonunu
çağırabilirsiniz
bs
test
efendim
yani
yukarıdaki
kodla
aşağıdaki
kod arasında
anlamsal
açıdan
bir fark yok
her ikisi de
5.
bitin
set edilip edilmediğini
kontrol ediyor
sınıyor
fakat burada
güzel fonksiyonlardan
biri
arkadaşlar
count fonksiyonu
doğrudan
tabi derleyicinin
implementasyonu
çok da hızlı
bu işi yapacak
şekilde
set edilmiş
bitlerin
sayısını
veriyor
yani örneğin
see out
hatta şöyle
yazalım
şöyle
askeri bir değer
oluşturalım
yazdıralım
ve see out
bs
count
arkadaşlar
count'un geri dönüş değeri
set edilmiş
bit sayısı
mesela şu anda
12 tane
bit
set edilmiş
ve gerçekten
yazdırmamışım
yazdırayım ayrıca
see out
bs
ayrı
buraya
örneğin
o zaman
iki tane bit
set edilmiş
olması lazım
değil mi
2'nin kuvveti
olduğuna göre
evet
count'un ne iş
yaptığını
anladınız mı
bs
any
any bit
bunların hepsi
Boolean değer
döndürüyor
arkadaşlar ne anlamda
is any bit
set
mesela
şöyle yapalım
bool alfa modunu
alalım
see out
bool alfa
burada
iostream
sınıflarını anlatırken
göreceğiz
bu konuyu da
anlatacağım
şüphesiz
burada
stream nesnesinin
format state'ini
değiştirip
Boolean değerleri
true false
olarak
yazmasını
sağlıyorum
artık bundan sonra
tekrar eski haline
getirene kadar
hep true false
olarak yazacak
şimdi
bütün bitler
sıfır
dolayısıyla
any
fonksiyonu
any bit
set ne döndürmeli
arkadaşlar
false döndürmeli
ama
setlerden
bitlerden
bir tanesini
set edeyim
örneğin
bs
köşeli
parantez
arkadaşlar
eşittir
ister
şöyle yazın
bs
set
yazın
ikisi aynı
anlamda
şimdi
any
fonksiyonu
true
değer döndürecek
yani en az
bir biti
set edin
ise
any
true
değer döndürüyor
non bunun
tersi
örneğin
sıfırken
none of the bit
set
evet
yani
türkçeye cevap
versek
evet
hiçbir bit
set edilmemiş
durumda
arkadaşlar
aksa halde
fosyar
döndürecek
şimdi bakın
şöyle yazalım
eksi
bir
küme parantez
kullanmadığım
için derneğin
en fazla uyarı
mesajı
verir
all
bütün bitler
set edilmiş
durumlarına
evet
çünkü bütün bitleri
bir
ama
en az bir biti
sıfır olsaydı
yes
reset
şimdi
all
fonksiyonu
true
yerine
fos
değer döndürecekti
bu fonksiyonları
anladık mı
any
all
efendim
none
basit fonksiyonlar
arkadaşlar
enumeration
türleriyle
birlikte
kullanabilirsiniz
mesela
bakınız
şöyle bir
enum
türüm
olsun
bu
enum
class da
olabilirdi
aslında
bu
değerler
number
of
colors
da
bu durumda
şimdi ben
şöyle kodlar
yazabilirim
artık
bit
setin
biliyorsunuz
bu
idiomatik
yapısı
ile de
çok
kullanılıyor
bit
setin
arkadaşlar
number of
colors
number
of
colors
açılımı
türünden
nesmi
şimdi
aslında problem
domeninde
bitlerin her biri
arkadaşlar
bir rengin
olup olmadığı
bilgisini
taşıyor
yani
sıfırıncı bit
white'ın
birinci bit
grey'in
ikinci bit
yellow'un
üçüncü bit
böyle gidiyor
o zaman
ben
daha okunaklı
olması için
böyle bir
yapıya başvurabilirim
mesela şöyle
yazabilirim
arkadaşlar
my setin
köşeli parantez
kırmızıyı
açayım
arada başka
kodlar var
efendim
sarıyı
açayım
boş
değil mi
ya da
siyahı
kapatayım
black
olsun
ya bu da
idiomatik olarak
çok sık
karşımıza çıkan
yapılardan
bir tanesi
arkadaşlar
evet
şimdi burada
ilginç bir durum var
karşılaştırma
işlemleri
bit set sınıfı
arkadaşlar
eşit ve eşit
değili
overload ediyor
zaten
c++
20 standartına
göre artık
eşit
değil yok
bu sınıflarda
eşitin
olması
eşit
değil
işlemini
derleyicinin
eşit
fonksiyonunu
çağırıp
onun
booleyn
değilini
almasını
zorunlu
hale getiriyor
o konuyu
henüz
anlatmadım
ama bu
c++
20'de
öncesinde
sınıfın
hem eşit
değil
fonksiyonları
var
yani
aynı türden
iki tane
bit set
nesnesini
arkadaşlar
eşitlik
ya da eşitsizlik
karşılaştırmasına
sokabilirsiniz
mesela
bakınız
bit set
nasıl bir örnek
yapalım
x
ya da
şöyle olsun
255 değil
bit set
y
c
x
eşit
y
x
köşeli parantez
eşittir
ve eşittir
false
tekrar eşitlik
karşılaştırmasına
soktum
eşit
çıkmadı
arkadaşlar
şimdi ben size
şöyle bir soru
sorsam
bit set
nesnelerini
container'da
tutabilir miyim
tabi ki bu
bu bir sınıf
mesela şöyle bir
container olabilir mi
arkadaşlar
vektörün
diyelim ki
buradaki bit set
nesneleri
hatta şöyle yazalım
using
file
flex
file flex
eşittir
bu bit set'in
açılımı
vektörün
file flex
açılımı
vek
bakın şimdi
vekin
pushback'i
bit set
vekin
emplace
peki
efendim
vekin
emplace
peki
bu da anlıyorsunuz
değil mi
emplace
pekle
pushback'in
arasındaki
farkı da
göstermiş
oluyorum
vekin
string
str
ab
vekin
emplace
peki
str
ab
emplace
peki
konteynerda
tutulan
tutulacak
öğelerin
konstruktörüne
geçilecek
argümanları
gönderiyorum
peki
şimdi
bakın
spor
auto
bs
iki nokta
üst üste
vec
yani range
base
for look
ve
co
bs
yani
konteynerda
tutulmasının
son derece
doğal bir durum
olduğunu
göstermek
için
yazdım
peki
soru
soruya
düşünerek
cevap
vermeye
çalışın
hemen
hızı
refleksle
cevap
vermeyin
sort
algoritm
başlık
dosyasını
dahil ettim
bsort
arkadaşlar
vektörünün
ismine
vecbegin
vecant
sort
fonksiyonunda
yapılan çağrı
sentaks hatası
oluşturur mu
oluşturmaz mı
a hata
b hata
değil
emiran
kaan can
hata var mı
yok mu
hata oluşturur
olsam
bravo
neden
az önceki
cümlemi
eğer kaçırmadıysanız
ben sınıfın
nesi olmadığını
söylemiştim
küçüktür
operatörü
olmadığını
söylemiştim
arkadaşlar
dolayısıyla
küçüktür
operatörü
olmadığı
için
ama
sortun
bu
overload'u
küçüktür
komparatörünü
kullandığı için
sentaks hatası
olacak
ama mesela
ben şöyle
yazsaydım
bakın bakın
arkadaşlar
lambda
oto
b1
uzun uzun
bitset yazmamak için
ama zaten
par paraks
dediğim için
arkadaşlar
neyse
oto
b1
ya da
oto
f1
f2
e
şimdi
küçüktür
karşılaştırması
yerine
benim
bir komparatör
sağlamam
gerekiyor
mesela
arkadaşlar
henüz
görmüyormuş
olsak da
f1'in
to
şöyle yazarsam
fonksiyonların
ismini de
gösterecek
file
flags
file flags
f1
evet bakın
geldi
to
ulong
arkadaşlar
küçük
return
tabi
f1
to
ulong
küçük
f2
u
ulong
şimdi
artık
küçüktür
operatörü
yok ama
komparatör
olarak
kullandığım
bir
gördüğünüz gibi
closure
type
var
dolayısıyla
syntax
hatası
olmayacak
aynı
durum
sette
tutmam
durumu
için de
geçerli
bakın
şimdi
set
başlık
dosyasını
dahil
ediyorum
ve
şunları
sildim
setin
file flags
açılımı
my set
and place
arkadaşlar
0 1
neden
syntax
hatası
ee
çünkü
bu
setin
ne
açılımı
arkadaşlar
setin
bit set
virgül
lessin
bit set
açılımı
ama
less yok
küçüktür
karşılaştırmasına
sokamam
ama
az önceki
kodu
geri dönelim
tekrar yazmak
istemiyorum
şimdi
bakın
vektör koduna
geri dönelim
şu
lambda
ifadesine
buradan alalım
şu
lambda
ifadesini
buradan
alalım
bunu
bir tür haline
getirelim
auto
p
eşittir
lambda
arkadaşlar
pile
flags
lhs
pile
flags
rhs
return
dönüşüm fonksiyonlarını henüz görmedik
ikinci derste göreceğiz
lhs'nin
tu
ulongu
rhs'nin
tu
ulongu
şimdi
sette bunu
komparatör türümü yaparsam
setin
pile
flex
virgül
decal
type'ın
decal type
pile
flex
closure
type'ı elde ettim
açılımı
özelliğin
decal type
pile
flex
değil
tabi
f
yanda
aldım
decal type
f
açılımı
my set
şimdi
artık
örneğin
my set'in
m
place'i
herhangi bir
syntax hatası
olmadığını
görüyorsunuz
özetle
küçüktür
operatörünün
olmadığını
tabi sadece
küçüktür
değil
küçük
eşit
büyük
operatörlerin
olmadığını
sadece eşit
eşit
ve eşit
değiller
olduğunu
anlayalım
hocam
onluk sistemde
büyük sayıları
yazarken
ondalıkları
ile ayırabiliyorduk
burada
mümkün mü
constructor string parametreli
olduğunda
hayır
o sabitlerin
yazımına ilişkin
bir
syntax kuralı
yazıya ilişkin
değil
yani bakın
şunların hepsi
legal
mesela
0b
auto
a
eşittir
0b
bu ikilik
sayı sisteminde
yazılmış
bir sabit
foto
b
onluk sayı sisteminde
yazılmış
bir sabit
foto
c
o eksadismal sayı sisteminde
yazılmış
bir sabit
hatta
auto
d
sizin
diliniz
özelliğe
digit
separator
dingo
nerede
kullandığım
mantıksal olarak
beni ilgilendiriyor
istersen şöyle bile
yazabilirim
yani neden
iki iki ayırıyorsun
diyecek mi
hayır
o anlamı
katan
benim
yani algılamayı
kolaylaştırmak için
örneğin
şöyle yazdığımı
düşünün
ya da
burada
binlik ayrıcı
gibi dursun
diye
ya da
burada
dörder dörder
hex
dijitleri
ayırmak için
hatta burada
gerçek sayı
sabitinin
tam sayı
kısmında bile
kullanabilirim
ama siz
bir stringte
bunu kullanırsanız
artık o stringteki
karakterlerden
biri olur
anladınız mı
bu bir
non-digit
karakteri
olduğu için
exception
prove
etmesine
neden olur
açıklamayı
anladınız mı
yani oradaki
digit separatorlar
bunu
karıştırmamak
gerekiyor
şimdi
arkadaşlar
bir de
operator overloading
tarafına
bakalım
hatta
şöyle bir
alt başlığımız
olsun
bit set
sınıfı
ve
operator
overloading
arkadaşlar
zaten
formatlı
girişik işlemleri
için
sınıfın
kendisi
operator
lab
çifti
ve operator
right
çifti
overload
etmiş
o yüzden
bakınız
see you
out
kat
izleyicom
var
US
przew
Yani tıpkı string sınıfında olduğu gibi bu fonksiyonları bana veren standart kütüphanenin kendisi bitleri girin.
Gördünüz değil mi? Tabi hakal bir bit olsaydı exception provetiydi.
Ama bunun yanında şu operatörlerde overload edilmiş bütün bitsel operatörler.
Yani bitsel ve bitsel özel veya bitsel sağa kaydırma bitsel sola kaydırma bitsel değil.
Bu operatörler bilirdiğimiz gibi bitsel operatörler ve bunlar overload edilmiş.
Yani örneğin şu işlemleri yapabilirsiniz.
Örneğin yani sadece bu işlemlerin legal olduğunu göstermek için bakın güzel bir kod yazalım.
Unside long
X, Y
Siyah
İki sayı giriniz
Böyle giriş daha kolay olsun diye
Şimdi bakın arkadaşlar
Siyah
Yalnız burada bir şeye dikkat etmek gerekiyor.
Bakın çok hatta mülakatlarda sorulan hafı karıştırıcı sorularla.
Arkadaşlar bu da operatör overloading, bu da operatör overloading.
Operatör overloading'in genel kurallarını hatırlayalım.
Operatörlerin öncelik seviyesini ve öncelik yönünü değiştiremezsiniz.
Lab çift operatörü nasıl normal primitif operatlarla kullanıldığında bitsel ve operatöründen daha yüksek öncelik değilse burada da öyle.
Yani böyle yazarsam aslında şuraya kadar bir problem yok.
Ama sanki burada bir parantez varmış gibi değil mi?
Burada problem bu fonksiyonun geri döndürdüğü Cout nesnesi bitsel ve operatörün operanda olamaz.
Böyle bir operatör overloading yok.
Dolayısıyla amacımızı ifade eden kod ifadenin parantez içine alınmasıyla mümkün.
Peki aynı şekilde arkadaşlar hatta bunları da yazdıralım.
Cout, Bs1, New Line, Bs2, New Line.
Arkadaşlar X ve Y demişim.
Bs1 ve Bs2 diyecektim.
Olsun Bs1, Bs2, Bs1, Bs2.
Gördüğünüz gibi bitsel ve operatörün operandı oluyorlar.
Bs, önce V'yi görelim.
Normal buradaki operatör overloading.
Bu X olsun, şu Y olsun arkadaşlar.
Görüyorsunuz.
Hatta şöyle alt satıra yazdıralım ki.
Alt altı gelsin.
Evet.
X
Y
Bakın 0, 1, 0
1, 1, 1
0, 1, 0 bildiğimiz bitsel V işlemi.
Eğer bitsel V işlemi yapmak istiyorsam
bitsel V operatörü de overload edilmiş durumda.
Şimdi işlem tablosunu biliyorsunuz zaten.
Evet.
Bu X, bu Y
1, 0, 1, 0, 0, 0
Sonucu 1 yapıyor.
Sonucun yanlış olması için ikisinin de false olması gerekiyor.
Bitsel, XOR
Arkadaşlar
İşlem tablosunu tabii ki biliyorsunuz.
Operatör
Aynıysa
Sonuç 0
Operatör
Farklıysa
Sonuç 1
165, 123
Evet bakın
1, 1, 0 değerini üretti.
Ama
Bitler
Farklıysa
0, 1, 1
Ya da 1, 0, 1
Evet.
Şimdi daha da ilginç
Bitsel veya bitsel
Değil Operatör
De overload edilmiş durumda.
Mesela bakın
BS1
Tilda
Aslında
BS1
Demek
Nokta
Operatör
Tilda'ya
Çağrı
Yap
Demek
BS2
Tilda
İki sayı
Giriniz
Evet bakın
Alttaki
Bitsel
Değili
Yine
Alttaki
Bunun
Bitsel
Değili
Daha da
İlginci
Operatör
Left
Shift
Ve Operatör
Right
Shift
Overload
Edilmiş
Şimdi bir tane sayı alalım
Sadece
Arkadaşlar
Ben
C++'ın
En komik kodlarından biri olarak
Bunu görüyorum
Bazen ben de
Mülakatlarda
Soruyorum
Diyorum ki
Bakınız
Elimde
Bitset
Mesnesi var
Bitset'in
Açılımı
BS
X
S
B
Arkadaşlar
Şimdi
Ya da şöyle
S
Arkadaşlar
Bakın şimdi
Gerçekten
Komik
Eğer
Böyle yazarsam
Bu ne anlama gelecek
Bu fonksiyon çağrılacak
BS'yi yazdıracak
Çağrılan bu fonksiyon
S alt nesnesini döndürecek
O da 3'ü yazdıracak
Yani şimdi
X'in bitlerini
Ve 3 yazacak
Öyle değil mi
Burada şunu demek istiyorum
Arkadaşlar
Burada
Soldan sağa
Öncelik yönü olduğu için
Buradaki
Left Shift
Bitwise Left Shift
Operatörü
Bitset sınıfının
Left Shift Operatörü
Değil
O stream sınıfına
İlişkin
Left Shift
Değil mi
Bir sayı giriniz
Mesela
Arkadaşlar
Yazdırdı
İşte bu sayının
4. biti
Sonra da 3 yazdırdı
Ama şöyle olsaydı
Durum
Tamamen
Değişecekti
Öyle değil mi
Şimdi
Bs'yi
3 sola
Kaydırılmasından
Elde edilen
Bitset'i
Döndürecekti
Operatör
Left Shift
Fonksiyonu
Arkadaşlar
Ve
Ben de
O stream sınıfının
Bu bitset sınıfının
Sağladığı
Insurter'la
3 sola
Kaydırılmış
Neyi yazdırmış
Olacaktım
Bitset değerini
Yazdırmış
Olacaktım
Yani örneğin
7 değerini
Girersem
En düşük anlamlı
3 biti
Ama 3 sola
Kaydırıldığı için
3 tane 0
Olacak
Sağda
Ondan sonra
3 tane
1 olacak
Anlaşıldı mı
Arkadaşlar
İzlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim